also the man himself here what canceled
the legend is here inshallah his new
home and
imagine the reward of helping the New
River to come to Islam to go umrah for
the very first time do you know how
strong it will keep them in their faith
and Islam brothers and sisters you can
be a part of the sponsorship Sisters by
giving just like many people have two
pounds five pounds or ten pounds please
please take this opportunity and get the
reward of every single ibad that they do
there inshallah sometimes in lifelong
sisters we can't really see the true
intentions of an individual are they
genuine are they not But as time goes we
see what they're really about
just like this oh that's much better I
can see more clearly your face brothers
and sisters Andrew Tate released well
his friend released a video of him in
Dubai and he said something along the
lines of inshallah he's come to his true
home or something along those lines and
we see him in the Masjid praying here's
the clips let's watch that and let's
learn five key lessons of how Muslims
should react not on the short
short-sighted but on the long term how
we should react to undertake except in
Islam or not come into Islam or is he
just using Islam let's watch his videos
first I told you also the man himself
here what canceled the legend is here
insha his new home and when I bring you
a very special show soon to all the
people who supported him his hallway bro
thank you very much man thank you glad
to be here
Allah
oh
guys what you saw there was Andrew Tate
with his friend Muslim friend and he's
in the Masjid now brothers and sisters
there's two things that you need to know
a person who believes Islam is true in
his heart but doesn't testify on the
tongue is known as a disbeliever because
he knows it's the truth but he doesn't
testify on his tongue like Abu Talib the
prophet's Uncle a person who doesn't
believe in his heart on his tongue is
known as a monafith somebody who is
pretending to be a it's like an imposter
trying to pretending to be a Muslim the
first thing that we need to learn is
this one sisters if Andrew Tate does
come to Istanbul he's already become a
Muslim we hope so because it seems like
he's praying and that could show the
action if the action is genuinely you
know Iman is connected to actions if the
actions purely that he believes this
then he's accepted Islam
um uh however some schools might say
that he has to testify it but the first
thing we need to do is what Allah says
in the Quran is
in the Quran
when there comes Allah's help and the
Victory and you see people entering
Allah's approved religion and multitudes
then pronounce the Purity and praise of
you Lord and seek forgiveness from him
surely he's ever relenting the first
thing we need to do is what we should
praise our Lord alhamdulillah that the
true religion is being seen by people
famous or not famous alhamdulillah the
first thing we need to do is praise
Allah number two what how should we
react
if undertake comes to Islam if he comes
to Islam brothers and sisters we should
not be like oh my God
okay you can't be happy we're not saying
don't be happy but don't tie Islam's
success and Islam being true and you're
Iman to an individual coming to Islam or
not we understand it and it can be like
you know like a bit tempting like oh my
gosh you know he accepted this time as
well it might it's good and it can be a
sign of showing that it's the True
Religion but on the long run brothers
and sisters we shouldn't do that why
because and we should assume the best of
course in this time we are told to
assume the best but um said we used to
judge people based on Revelation
Revelation is stopped now we judge from
what's apparent behind me you can see
that there's a colors changing I don't
know what color it is now is it blue it
might turn to pink it might turn to
Green it might turn to Red the point is
this people go through different phases
people may have different intentions we
have to assume the best which I'm going
to come to later but we cannot tie
Islam's success based on individual
because what if we tomorrow
let's suppose he didn't accept Islam
okay let's suppose he didn't accept
Islam let's suppose he accepted Islam
and leaves Islam so what so what we are
happy if he comes for his own good
alhamdulillah for his salvation we're
happy for him of course do we want
anyone to go Hell Fire of course not
we're happy for that he's joined the
family however if he decides to leave
what we're going to do cry about it they
have doubts about Islam our Imam is
going to go down no that's why tie
yourself to Allah not individuals okay
number three some people are coming and
saying you know what he's got some Auto
different motives he's doing it for fame
or clown this is trying to get Muslim
audience Etc look these are valid
concerns we understand it can be the
possibility but we have evidence from
the Quran and this we have evidence from
the Sunnah that a man came to the
prophet peace be upon him and said I was
in the battlefield fighting a enemy of
Islam yes okay in the battlefield and I
was about to strike him now kill him and
he said I said Islam but he was too
struck him because I knew he was saying
that because he just wanted to save his
life and the process got so angry he
said did you open his heart and did you
see his intentions well like he rebuked
the companion how could you say that how
could you make these assumptions and
based on what nothing and you took his
life brothers and sisters if Andrew
Taylor accepted Islam then you are going
to be slandering him we don't we look we
if he seems like he's been positive
towards Islam Etc you know like before
the stuff that his son is said which is
wrong there's pros and cons to it but
we've seen him say very good stuff about
Islam so we need to assume the best
until there is evidence we can't just
judge and be like oh if he does oh I
told you guys so no it doesn't Islam
doesn't work like that we judge the
Sharia cause for for us if he's accepted
Islam we look at evidence to say that
he's a Believer I will do that if the
Sharia quotes for us to rebuke him or
rebuke him but the point is we shouldn't
go down this route of assuming the worst
and we have the evidence from the Hadith
number four brothers and sisters some
people are coming and saying oh but he's
still committing harama he's lying is
not Muslim when has committing sins
minor or major made one a disbeliever I
mean this was ideology of Hawaii you
know and I'm not saying by the way let's
be clear here we know some people of
absolute ignorance claim an individual
people are coverage because they said
something pertaining to that I'm not
saying that but what I'm saying is we
don't have that belief we shouldn't say
that we shouldn't say oh
this person cannot accept Islam because
it's committed sins
if Islam was to come with nobody would
have come to Islam what does that mean
that means brothers and sisters when
we're giving down we always do it the
wrong way around we come to people okay
now we're going to teach you what's
Haram this is
but the point is this if we did our
Tower the right way
once you enter Iman and teach person the
person of beauty of toheed and the ugly
side of shirk once Iman enters the heart
they will let go of Haram their self and
they will Embrace Halal themselves we do
it the opposite way around and this does
makes Islam look as if it's just a
robotic religion and there's just some
protocols you need to follow Islam is so
much spiritual and deeper than that it's
more than don't follow this guy it is
misguided and this this kind of
prophetic things that make people run
away from Islam so Islam is much more
deeper than that and that's my fourth
point my last my brothers and sisters
also I'm going to touch upon is in shall
have an interview with Andrew Tate it's
very soon on this channel we're going to
find out has he already become a Muslim
would he accept Islam then we don't know
no but the point is brothers and sisters
the point is this that we need to
acknowledge and understand that
if he comes to Islam we are happy for
him and my last point is this
just know that your heart your innate
disposition we have something called the
fitra that everything that you have the
money the cause the woman the houses the
holidays or whatever it may be
there is nothing that you can give the
soul that could feed it except accept
the worship of God Allah says in the
Quran indeed in his remembrance do
hearts find peace and if you forgive us
remembers you'll have a depressed life
meaning what just as you give your
stomach food it eats and has nutrition
if you give it the wrong food it vomits
out the soul is exactly like that if you
give it anything other than it's
reminisce of his Lord and his gratitude
to his Lord and his worshiped to his
Lord it will reject it money cause
whatever it may be and you know very
well yes okay I'm not going to say I
live the lifestyle like yours maybe a
little bit similar not to that degree
but nothing I gave it made it happy
until I feel my shackles from
enslavement to society and the Matrix we
want to call it and enslave myself to
the true creator who deserves My Worship
that is when I found my true freedom and
brothers my dear brother Andrew T
inshallah if you accept Islam know that
your hearts will only find peace your
heart only in his remembrance Allah
that's it from sisters until next time
hope you guys benefited video don't
forget to watch from mohammedab and
Andrew Tate's discussion and make dwell
from inshallah if he's accepted on the
way to accept Islam it doesn't accept
Islam alhamdulillah till next time